Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Buonasera, mi chiamo Gianluca Busilacchi,
sono ricercatore all'Università di Macerata in Sociologia Economica,
lavoro da dieci anni circa come ricercatore,
mi occupo tendenzialmente di politiche sociali,
però mi sono anche occupato, negli ultimi anni,
soprattutto di sviluppo locale nella Regione Marche.
Che cosa fa, soprattutto, il sociologo economico?
Cerca di capire quali elementi del territorio sono importanti
per lo sviluppo economico di una regione,
quindi un mestiere un po' diverso, diciamo, dall'economista.
Secondo me la cosa interessante, soprattutto per un'iniziativa come questa,
potrebbe essere cercare di capire come oggi la cultura
e territori che sono fertili
dal punto di vista della conoscenza e della cultura
siano utili per lo sviluppo locale.
Vorrei evitare un po' di, come dire, andare sul luogo comune
secondo cui la cultura produce sviluppo
perché produce posti di lavoro.
Questo, è appunto, un luogo comune che, ahimè,
rischia di essere anche smontato abbastanza facilmente.
Io credo che invece potrebbe essere interessante
cercare di capire come la cultura possa essere un fattore di sviluppo
da un altro punto di vista,
cioè come un territorio che è culturalmente fertile
può essere un territorio anche accattivante
per creare uno sviluppo economico
anche non direttamente legato alla cultura.
Vorrei analizzare questo ragionamento da due punti di vista.
Primo elemento. Soprattutto se guardiamo alla realtà marchigiana,
che è una realtà di piccola e media impresa, noi abbiamo avuto nelle Marche
uno sviluppo dei cosiddetti distretti industriali.
Perché nelle Marche, e in altre regioni analoghe alle Marche?
Perché nelle Marche c'erano alcuni elementi legati
all'etica del lavoro dei marchigiani, alla manualità dei marchigiani,
al saper fare dei marchigiani e anche alla fiducia
che si creava in determinati contesti,
che rendevano questi contesti territoriali particolarmente accattivanti
per la crescita e la fertilizzazione di imprese.
Che cosa vuol dire accattivanti? Vuol dire che in alcuni territori,
per esempio laddove è nato il distretto calzaturiero,
c'erano delle cosiddette economie esterne.
Che cosa sono le economie esterne?
Sono dei vantaggi, in termini di costo per chi produce,
non direttamente legati all'aspetto produttivo, ma esterni ad esso.
In questi territori, nel fermano-maceratese ma anche nel pesarese,
o anche in altre parti del nordest d'Italia, c'erano, appunto,
alcuni di questi elementi, alcuni di quelli che dicevo prima.
C'era un saper fare,
c'era una tradizione artigiana per il settore calzaturiero,
c'era anche un clima di fiducia tra i cittadini di questi piccoli paesi,
che permetteva che gli imprenditori si conoscessero tra di loro
e riuscissero a creare, appunto, delle economie di scala
e dei rapporti tra loro che permettevano di creare il distretto,
perché abbassavano i cosiddetti costi di transazione,
cioè quei costi che ogni impresa ha quando deve prendere informazioni
su un'altra impresa. Queste cose non c'erano.
C'era bassa criminalità, c'era un clima di fiducia di tutta la comunità.
Allora, detto molto sinteticamente, questi sono stati gli elementi
che hanno fatto crescere il cosiddetto “modello marchigiano”.
Ora, questi elementi sono andati in crisi negli ultimi anni,
perché queste imprese, questo genere di imprese, sono chiaramente
più esposte - manifattura semplice, a basso valore aggiunto -
alle crisi internazionali. Questo avviene in tutto il mondo occidentale.
Oggi i distretti che riescono sono invece di altro genere,
cioè sono i distretti con un alto valore aggiunto, i distretti tecnologici,
sono distretti dove si produce un altro genere di beni.
Allora, dopo questa lunga introduzione, che cosa c'entra la cultura?
C'entra per due ragioni, come dicevo prima.
Primo, quali sono oggi i nuovi elementi accattivanti,
quali sono i fattori che fanno nascere questi nuovi distretti
e non quelli di prima?
Questi nuovi distretti nascono laddove ci sono due elementi.
Primo: vicinanza ai centri di conoscenza, di solito centri di ricerca,
ma non pensiamo solamente ai centri di ricerca “hard”,
cioè fisica, ingegneria; certo, quelli sono opportuni,
ma è opportuno avere dei centri di ricerca in cui ci sia, appunto,
una ricerca, una sperimentazione, quindi Università,
però anche realtà in cui, come dire, la conoscenza
è un fattore determinante dello sviluppo ed investimento.
Secondo elemento, molto importante,
questi distretti sorgono laddove è alta la qualità della vita,
perché se i distretti non nascono dal basso ma sono elementi importati,
occorre che ingegneri, manager, con le loro famiglie, vi si trasferiscano,
ed è quello che è avvenuto nella Silicon Valley,
o nel sud dell'Inghilterra, intorno alla zona di Oxford,
dove c'erano centri di ricerca ma c'era anche un'alta qualità della vita
rispetto, ad esempio, alle grandi città, a Los Angeles o a Londra,
e quindi era interessante per, appunto, alcuni quadri di impresa
trasferirsi lì con le loro famiglie.
E allora, appunto, secondo aspetto, la cultura, l'attenzione all'ambiente,
alla qualità della vita, all'enogastronomia,
diventano indirettamente fattori di attrazione, fattori di sviluppo.
Ecco, io credo che, vedendola da questo punto di vista,
creare dei territori in cui si faccia sperimentazione culturale,
in cui la cultura possa diventare anche trasversalmente
un elemento trainante per tutta una comunità di ricercatori e,
secondo aspetto, in cui la cultura possa essere anche
un elemento della qualità della vita,
in cui la presenza anche del prodotto culturale diventa poi
un elemento importante per la qualità della vita - come dire,
la cultura sì che diventa un fattore di sviluppo.
Quindi credo che se si riusciranno a mettere in piedi questi percorsi,
insomma, credo che riusciremo per davvero a considerare la cultura
un fattore di sviluppo a tutto tondo, anche secondo una prospettiva
più difficilmente attaccabile, perché purtroppo la prima prospettiva,
quella per cui la cultura dev'essere vista come fattore di sviluppo
solo perché produce lavoro è una prospettiva che ovviamente è giusta,
però non è sufficiente da sola a giustificare il rapporto
tra il nuovo sviluppo locale e appunto le attività culturali,
i territori culturalmente creativi.